So, looking at the material system in a little bit more depth here, we've got the material
editor overview which you can see which is just a buildup of the base color, the metallic
and the roughness that we were looking at previously where you can see some text quads
going on with texture samples and roughness values and we've got normal maps going on
with some baked ambient occlusion as well and so I'll jump into the editor and show
you a basic material set up in a second and just to talk to you about the parent materials
and the material instances, essentially we can have this parent material which is from
the slide previously that can be a parent material so we can say this is a parent rock
material and these are all the properties that we want and as you can see roughness
for example is a value here which we'll actually be able to manipulate in a child version of
the material so we can have parent materials and material instances which are child versions
of that material so we could set a roughness value in the parent material for example and
then using that same material we can create instances of that to have you know materials
with different roughnesses for example which is really powerful and it gives it a better
more optimized workflow as well. So material instances come with all the same properties
as a parent material and you can you know enable and disable them and right now we'll
jump into the editor and to show you a basic material set up, how to author a material
and get it working with a material instance inside your editor.